[MUSIC PLAYING]
|
LAURENCE MORONEY: Hi.
Welcome to GeoCasts, where you
can walk your way through what
you can do with Google Maps.
I'm Laurence Moroney, and in
this first part of the series,
I'm going to talk about how
you can get rich mapping
functionality in your
apps with very little work
by delegating it to Google Maps.
Say you need some basic
capabilities in your mobile app
to link out to a map, show
directions to a location,
or display what the destination
looks like Street View.
Delegation is the
easiest way to do this.
The key to this is
in using URL schemes.
A URL scheme allows your
app to open another app.
Using the Google Maps URL
scheme you can, for example,
have your users
open the Google Maps
app from within your
own app, and then you
can configure the app
to open at a location
that you want, with a
route that you want,
and many other
mapping scenarios.
Here you can see how you can use
a URL scheme and an Android app
through using
Google Maps Intense.
You can see how to look
at a particular location,
view restaurants in San
Francisco, navigate to a place,
even see a street view
of the Swiss Alps.
Now, you can use URL Schemes
and iOS with the same effect.
But because not all iOS users
have Google Maps installed,
you can fall back to
launching the Google Maps
website in the app's
absence with code like this.
So that's it.
The first step in
walking your way
through what you
can do with maps,
and how you can control the
Google Maps app or Google Maps
site using URL schemes, and it
will do all the work for you.
Now that's all very
nice, but it does
involve people leaving your app
if you want to give them a map.
If you want to keep them in
your app, take a look at part 2.
[MUSIC PLAYING]